get started so this is the final session
of the conference on
algebraic and circuit complexity and the
first talk is on complexity measures on
the symmetric group
and beyond and nathan is going to give
the talk
so nathan great
okay so uh yeah so let's just get right
into it
okay so recall that the definition of
fourier degree on the hypercube is as
follows
so here f hat of s this uh denotes the
fourier coefficient corresponding to the
subset s
and also recall that this coincides with
the definition of
degree of the degree of f as a real
multilinear
polynomial okay so
that was uh fourier complexity let's
talk about decision tree complexity so
decision tree complexity is defined as
follows it's the least possible depth of
a decision tree t
that computes a boolean function f so
the following two facts are known about
the relationship between the fourier
complexity and decision tree complexity
and when you have two theorems of this
nature we say that these two
complexity measures are polynomially
related
okay so we won't have time to even
scratch the surface of all these
different complexity measures that are
out there
but uh just bear in mind that all the
natural ones that folks study tend to be
polynomially related
okay so this talks all about going
beyond the hypercube and
there's a lot of recent work in
theoretical cs that has done so
uh here's just a few works that i know
of from the past two years it's by no
means by no means comprehensive
but a perfectly reasonable question at
this point is to ask whether or not we
can export our boolean functions toolkit
to these other more exotic combinatorial
domains
and uh one wouldn't want to do this on
an ad-hoc basis
so really the question is is there is
there a good abstract framework for
studying complexity measures on other
combinatorial domains
and here i've just listed a few
combinatorial domains again not
comprehensive
but is there an abstract domain that
captures all these maybe
sorry an abstract framework that
captures all these so uh one of the
merits of our work is uh
that we propose an abstract some
political complex-based framework that
captures
many but not all of these combinatorial
structures
okay just to give you a taste of what
this framework looks like we start off
with the universe of atomic symbols
and then we define a domain and the
domain is just a uh
it's just a set x whose members are in
subsets
of u where n is some fixed natural
number
okay so we want to do things like define
decision tree complexity in this
abstract framework so we need an
abstract notion of what a query is
and that's defined as follows it's just
a subset of the universe that intersects
each member of my domain in exactly one
point
and with each domain x we can we
associate a set uh fancy queue of
allowed
queries okay and so there's a lot of
other parameters that are needed to
formally define these other complexity
measures to these
in this more general setting uh please
consult the full version of the paper on
the archive for these details
so let's just take the hypercube how do
we squeeze the hypercube into this
abstract framework that we've defined
well first we let our universe be the
following cartesian product
and now we're going to identify each bit
string as follows
okay so it's it's a very natural
identification here and
let's uh consider a different domain how
about permutations so what should the
universe be for permutations
well it's the it's this cartesian
product and
we make a similar identification here so
i comma pi i where pi i is the image of
i
right and so you can do this for a
variety of other combinatorial domains
again see the full version of the
archive paper if you want to know how we
were able to model some of
your favorite combinatorial object as a
uh and
in the simplicial complex framework
okay so let's revisit this decision tree
complexity so recall that with the
decision tree complexity of the internal
nodes these represent queries and so
we're
asking whether or not uh index i is a
zero or a one
so if we so if we now look at
permutations
uh there's a very natural analog of this
and so instead of asking uh if each um
coordinate is a zero or one we're asking
uh questions of the following
sentence so so of the following type so
like
for permutation pi does uh does where
does i get sent
or for uh or what gets sent to k
these are the queries that we're asking
in our internal nodes and notice that
i've omitted some notes here to keep
the picture brief but uh each internal
node has uh in children and
so right so so now we just have the same
definition as before for decision tree
complexity
uh for permutations so i the
the decision tree complexity of a
function is just the smallest
tree of this form that computes my
my boolean function over permutations
okay so uh that just gives you a taste
of
just just for decision tree complexity
but we were able to do this for a lot of
different
uh complexity measures and so our main
theorem is that we were able to show
that
all these complexity measures when we
generalize them in this uh
abstract simplicity complex framework
they're all polynomially related
and uh and we're able to do this for uh
a bunch of
various combinatorial domains that i
won't list
okay so uh one thing that i want to
point out though that uh
this theorem is nice but another main
result is actually
just coming up with the right
definitions for these things because
it's very easy to come up with the
definitions for things that seem natural
at first but
when you compare them to others they're
just not polynomially related and so i'd
uh in the remaining time that we have i
just kind of want to walk us through
this process
uh and show you the subtleties for
something as simple as like say degree
on uh on arbitrary domains
so if you want to talk about degree you
need to know what a function is
or sorry a polynomial so a polynomial is
uh just
we have the following natural definition
so it's just a linear combination
of uh carefully chosen indicator
functions
okay and so the degree of a polynomial
is just going to be the largest s
such that its corresponding coefficient
is not zero and now
the degree of a boolean function over an
arbitrary domain x
is just the least degree of a polynomial
p that represents that function
okay so for this definition to be
natural it needs to
correspond to 48 degree like we
witnessed for the hypercube on slide one
of this talk
so okay so what does 48 degree even mean
for an arbitrary x
so it turns out that the right
algebraic object to consider here is the
permutation representation of a
symmetric group acting on your domain
and so now this emits a decomposition
into irreducible representations of the
symmetric group
and these are indexed by integer
partitions
okay so now we're in a position to
define fourier degree and that's just
defined as follows if the representation
theoretic stuff is tripping you up
this is just like the fourier degree for
the hypercube only now we're considering
integer partitions rather than subsets
and our notion of size is uh the number
of cells
under the first row of the integer
partition so we
draw that picture think of it as a phase
diagram and look at the number of cells
under the first row
okay so i've given two different
definitions of
degree here one in polynomial land and
this other one in
representation theory land and so it's
not at all obvious why these things
should be equal but
for many domains it turns out that they
actually are equal and this uh draws
upon
some deep results that have been
happening in extremal combinatorics over
the past decade or so
so uh just to wrap things up here's the
degree
here's like our visualization of fourier
complexity on the hypercube
so this is what the picture looks like
for arbitrary domains so we're just
swapping out
subsets for integer partitions and the
notion of a size is just
the number of cells under the first row
okay so that's uh
that's the end so let's just conclude
with a few open questions real quickly
so this framework that we have doesn't
capture q analogs
so how do you do them we don't know uh
also we've had difficulty uh
uh extending our sensitivity results to
hierographical type matchings um so see
the full paper for what's going on there
uh real loose uh real this vague
question but uh
is there some sort of deeper explanation
for why
polynomial degree and and like fourier
degree are coinciding for some of these
uh
more abstract and exotic combinatorial
domains
um that would be that would be really
interesting
to uh figure out and uh finally uh
applications so we have a but we have
this framework that we've developed
and it would be great if we could uh
find some applications of this framework
to
various problems in theoretical cs okay
thank you very much
thank you uh so uh we
okay the talk went a little over one
minute over time so let's move on to the
next talk quickly
so the next oh no no sorry i didn't
interrupt you uh
uh the next talk is by jebel lynn
um who's going to talk about the
complexity of counting csp
so if you can share your slides
still so can you say nice query uh yes
yes we can
okay nesta
okay uh hi everyone uh i'm jabali
and i will introduce my result on the
complexity of continuous spd
yes csp is not constrained satisfaction
problem
and here in the d means that
every variable appears a multiple of d
times
and i will introduce the motivation
later but now let's start with the
definition
of counting sp
in constraint satisfaction problems we
use relations
to express constraints but in counting
problems
especially in weighted content problems
it's more convenient to consider
functions and when we talk about
functions we will always fix a finite
domain d
in particular in particular if q equals
2 and then d is called a boolean domain
and the function of arid k on d is a map
from d to the k to complex numbers
now we start the now we come to the
definition of counties
b let f be a finite set of functions
within on the following problem by
justice pf
and instance have some variables and
some constraints
and each constraint is a function from
the big f
applied on top of variables
and we say the instance i defines the
function f
i it's the product of all these
constraint functions
and the output of the problem is in the
sum
of all function values of f i and
the sum is also called the partition
function in statistical physics
we can use different constraint
functions to express
many important counting problems and the
graph parameters
so the question is what's the complexity
of evaluating the partition function
intuitively to compute such a
exponential sum
we can avoid brute force enumeration
only when the function f5 has a very
nice structure
and the idea was formulated by
zingitae and citroen
they proved that economic theorem for
contingencies p
that is in the problem such as pf is in
polynomial time
if not wf satisfies three conditions
otherwise in problems should be hard
here
i will not introduce the three
conditions because they are little
complicated
and the set wf contains all the
functions
defined by the csp instances
and using the same idea i can prove that
economy theorem for
contains spd the family was first
considered by huang and lu here d is a
positive
integer and the problem spd
is the restriction of csp to the
instances where
every variable occurs multiple of d
times
and then the criteria for content cspd
is similar to net for content csp
yes still in the three conditions but
now
the three conditions are imposed on the
functions defined by
instances of contingencies pd
so a question is why we need to consider
context pd
in the definition looks a little
artificial
in fact is they naturally arise in the
study of hormone problems
the hormone is more it's a more general
framework
than content csp yes it can also express
many pro
other problems like machines
holding problems have been intensively
studied for many years
but the dichotomy still remains
open even on the boolean domain
an interesting an interesting fact is
to classify holding problems we will
always need to
build the reductions from continuous spd
and other problems like machines
so to understand holding problems it's
very important to understand continuous
pd
before my result there are only partial
results on the boolean domain
and the criteria for this dichotomy is
explicit on the function set f but they
are
complicated to to prove
and now of course we have dichotomy
theorem for
general domains but it's too general to
to say much about the boolean domain
so in the second result of my paper is a
dichotomy for speedy on the
body domain it's more explicit and
i think such criteria is
sufficient for the study of hormone
problems
on the body domain of course
so finally conclusions and open
questions
prev previous results on chassis spd
focus
on the set of constrained functions they
are explicit
and but complicated to prove
and then this result failed to classify
our own problems
in this paper we can see i can see the
functions generated by f and the ideas
are from the
uh content csp on general domains
and i can achieve in full dichotomy for
content cspd and the proofs are very
simple
of course they are based on context sp
here are two open questions and the
first
is can we derive explicit criteria for
boarding content cspd
i think it's possible but i think it's
not
not very easy so i think it's better to
do this when
we really to really need to do
yeah and then the second is
can we apply the ideas to directly to
holland province
and yes i think these ideas are variable
and
indeed i have some partial results on in
this direction
and that's all thank you
thank you so we have time for one quick
question
uh before we start the next talk
otherwise if not then we can just keep
the questions to the end and start the
next talk
okay it's not then uh let's uh the next
talk is by george georgia who's going to
tell us about
uh tensor isomorphic isomorphous
complexity of isomorphism problems
uh josh a few yeah
all right do you see my slides yeah
great all right uh yeah thanks uh
ninja and thanks to the organizers for
all their hard work and making a
a great conference for us here um so i'm
josh grochow from uh university of
colorado boulder and i wanted to tell
you about my joint work with yeoming
chao from
university of technology sydney on
tensor isomorphism
so tensor isomorphism uh arises from a
wide variety of different places
in graphitemorphism it's one of the key
obstacles to getting further
improvements uh in geometric complexity
theory it shows up when you try to
understand the
borders of certain complexity classes uh
it's been
proposed as hard enough to be useful for
post-quantum cryptography it shows up in
de-randomizing symbolic determinant
identity testing turns out to be
basically the same problem as
classifying quantum entangled states up
to local operations
and it also shows up in machine learning
as the signature tensor
which is actually for those of you who
know the difference actually a genuine
tensor and not just
a multi-dimensional array of numbers
that ml people will sometimes call a
tensor
this one is actually a genuine tensor
isomorphism problem
um but it turns out that uh prior to our
paper the complexity of this problem
hadn't been very well studied
uh so we actually looked at uh many many
different problems but i just want to
tell you about
uh three of them briefly here uh so the
first is maybe
uh the most familiar which is polynomial
equivalence which i'll call
isomorphism because we have lots of
equivalence relations floating around
uh so you're given two polynomials say
by their list of coefficients
and you ask is there an invertible
linear change of basis
linear change of variables that
transforms one to the other
the second problem we consider is matrix
p group isomorphism so i give you
two m tuples of n by n matrices over a
finite field say invertible matrices
and i look at the groups that they
generate and because it's over a finite
field these are necessarily finite
groups and i ask are those groups
isomorphic
and then finally the detensory
isomorphism problem which is basically
the same
as uh equivalence of d particle quantum
states
here i give you two d dimensional arrays
as input so instead of a matrix which
has
rows and columns here we now have d
dimensions so you have rows columns
depths and
so on up to d and i ask are there
d invertible matrices a 1 up to a d
such that when i apply a 1
to the first index and so on and a d to
the d
index does that transform one tensor
into the other
okay uh so what's known about the
complexity of these problems well
they're all graph isomorphism hard due
to a variety of people depending on
which problem you're talking about for
all of them
the best known algorithm is essentially
brute force q to the n
squared um which is your your brute
forcing
over finding the n by n invertible
transformation
uh and in some of these cases there are
uh average case
q to the end results which is always a
nice improvement over q to the n squared
but in the case of group isomorphism
uh that's actually particularly
significant as this q to the n here
is polynomial time in the order of the
group
um so uh they all sort of
sit in the same land in terms of
complexity
and the question is can we formally
relate them
uh and in particular for detents or
isomorphism when d is like one or two
it's vectors and matrices it's very easy
but when d is three it starts to get
hard and the question is
as d gets bigger does it continue to get
harder and harder do you have sort of an
infinite hierarchy
or for quantum states as you increase
the number of particles you're looking
at
uh does this get harder and harder um
so this is a partial picture of sort of
the world of isomorphism problems uh
prior to our paper
i'll just highlight a few things graph
isomorphism some algebra isomorphism
problems over here uh polynomial
equivalence problems over here ring
isomorphism tensor isomorphism matrix
group isomorphism
uh and you see there are many previous
reductions uh but it's kind of a crazy
world
and so the the precursor to our results
was a previous paper with future and
sergey trick where we showed that
for three tensor equivalence problems um
where
i could give you maybe a tuple of three
tensors and they're actually blocked
into chunks
and you want the same matrix to act in
certain places and it's inverse in other
places and whatever you want
those all just reduce to three tensor
isomorphism
and so uh 3ti is universal for these
problems
in the same way that graph isomorphism
is universal for isomorphism of
finitely given structures but here
instead of explicitly given the
things are given now by by bases
okay um and so our results uh in this
paper with yum chao
complement these so the first is that
for any constant d
at least three d tensor isomorphism is
equivalent to three tensor isomorphisms
so you don't get an infinite hierarchy
uh and the second is uh reductions in
the opposite direction
to the results above which is that three
tensor isomorphism reduces to all of
these other problems
uh and so they're all equivalent and we
call them all ti complete
uh so the picture which used to look
like this now looks like this so
everything in the box is ti complete
this box over here has some footnotes
because some of these results have some
restrictions on which fields they work
over
but morally and over many fields they
are in fact still ti complete
so it really sort of simplifies the
landscape here so i just want to quickly
give you
a little bit of a flavor of these
reductions this is a reduction from
tensor isomorphism to alternating matrix
space isometry
i won't tell you what that is but i will
tell you it's a q analog of graph
isomorphism
uh and yoming chao my co-author has a
lot of papers now
taking graph parameters and giving their
q analogues for alternating matrix
spaces so there's a whole emerging
theory there and okay you know i haven't
told you what's going on here but you
can sort of see i have some tensor a
here and i do minus a transpose here and
i have some identity blocks here
it's it's a gadget style reduction it's
in three dimensions so you have to you
know it's a little bit complicated to
think about
um but it's a gadget style reduction uh
but the reduction from detents or
isomorphism to three-tenths or
isomorphism really looks different
and for that we go through algebra
isomorphism and then we appeal to
previous results that reduce algebra iso
to
three tensor isomorphism uh and
what the algebra we use is a quotient of
the path algebra of
this graph you see here or this multi
graph
and you could write down this whole
thing as a big tensor with
various ones and zeros and coefficients
all over the place but it would be a big
mess
but when you phrase it in terms of these
algebras a lot of bit pops out nicely
and we really do use sort of you know
the the full
meat of the theory of associated
algebras um
uh the jacobson radical the wetterburn
melsev theorem uh and so on
in order to get this proof to work um
after the fact we actually discovered
that gregoriov had used similar algebras
uh but simpler ones uh showing that the
isomorphism for them was equivalent to
graph isomorphism so it turns out
if you extend them a little bit you get
something that's ti complete
um so i just want to end with some open
questions the first is a little bit of a
mystery which is we're used to
uh jumps in complexity from two to three
like two set to three sat
um and this happens for tensors also so
two tensor isomorphism a two tensor is
just a matrix
this is basically just do two matrices
have the same rank
so it's in p three ti is now universal
and ti complete but not
np complete so it's in coam so if it
were np-complete
the hierarchy would collapse um and so
the question is what's going on here is
is there some more general notion of
universality that
fits all of these under one umbrella um
some other open questions
can you get any algorithm better than
the q to the n squared
and i just remind you while poly n would
be great q to the n would solve some of
the hardest
cases of group isomorphism in polynomial
time in the order of the group
which is one of these bottlenecks for
graph isomorphism
our random instances hard for sat
solvers you know what can you say using
algebraic proof complexity here
uh what happens over different rings um
in fact
even relating tensor isomorphism over
say f2 or f3
uh to each other is interesting all of
our results relate
problems over one field to problems over
the same field um
what about other groups instead of just
saying invertible matrices you could say
i want them to be orthogonal or so on
and you can start to talk about things
like lattice isomorphism
so there are lots of interesting
problems here um
and uh right so just to summarize you
know tensor isomorphism arises
in a lot of different places uh many
many problems turned out to be
equivalent to it and so we sort of
uh gave it this name ti complete and
then one last tiny word why did we call
this part one
well part two actually already exists
it's in our archive paper we just
haven't pulled it out into a separate
part two but if you want a preview of
that
you can check it out there and that's
all i wanted to say so thank you
great thank you josh and uh after any
questions we have time for one quick
question
uh if not actually i have a question so
uh
if i understood correctly a quality of
your result is that checking equivalence
between let's say
uh degree four polynomials is it the
same complexity as degrees three
polynomials so there is no hierarchy
there
degree two would just be matrix uh thing
so
it's actually a little subtle uh
i have to think carefully because
there's some issues with the fields and
um so morally it says that
i don't want to claim without thinking
about a little bit more whether it
actually says that
okay yeah okay uh
okay so let's move on to the next talk
then the
next talk is by ben lewalk who is going
to tell us about
polynomial degree bound and equations
for non-widget matrices and small
circuits
uh ben okay great yes all right thank
you for uh
reading the title instead of me uh
so yeah this is what i'm going to talk
about did a joint work with uh with sam
rinald from iit bombay
uh and if you don't know this word it's
it's fine and we'll
start from the beginning uh well first
thing is that you know we want to prove
low circuit level super linear low
circular bounds for strong models and
it's a
kind of a hard problem as you probably
know
uh one one special case is moving low
bars from computing linear functions or
linear transformation
uh from f to the n to f to the n f is a
is some field the good thing about
linear functions
is that they are computed with a
[Music]
pretty simple model which is called
linear circuits
so a linear circuit is uh um
here we have this definition by a
picture it's a
it's a circuit as usual it's just a
graph but it only uses
linear operations so uh the inputs and
then
every inner gate computes uh
maybe which is there are n inputs and n
outputs and every inner gate computes a
linear combination
of its children so the edges are all
labeled so for example this gate has a
inner
edge as in going edges labeled by alpha
and beta
so it just computes alpha times x1 plus
beta times x2
and and so on so uh
so that's a that's a pretty general and
powerful model actually for computing
linear functions uh if you think of
known
way non-algorithms for computing
well what linear functions are there so
one example is
discrete fluid transform similar things
and
fft for example is just a linear circuit
and you can show that any
any algebraic algorithm for computing in
our functions will
in fact without loss of generality be of
this four so it's it's quite a
general model when we want to prove
super linear circular bounds for some
explicit in our function
again over some field for this talk
the field will be complex numbers it's
not super important but just
let's just stick with something
[Music]
all right so yes we don't know how to do
it one
way that was suggested for analyzing
this model
it was given by valiant and what i
improved that if
m is a matrix such that the linear
transformation represented by m
as a linear circuit of logarithmic depth
and linear size
then you can decompose m as a sum r
plus s where r is a low rank matrix and
s is a sparse matrix and the precise
parameters are
no rank epsilon n and s velocity and
one plus epsilon this is for every
constant
[Music]
so uh just as a name we call the matrix
irs rigid if you cannot write it
as such a sum and and we want to find
explicit rigid matrices and it's again
an open problem we still don't know how
to do it after many years
we don't know how to do it with
parameters that will imply any circuit
load balance which
uh which these are the parameters
epsilon n and
one plus epsilon uh
so we we don't do it in this paper we
just
uh but we look at this
a set of rigid or non-legit matrices and
we try to say some interesting things
about it
and more generally we look at the set of
matrices that
or linear transformation that have small
in our circuits and we say
a similar thing about it and i will
explain what
what is the interesting properties mean
in this context uh
for that i need to to
uh give some notation so
let's imagine you know we have this set
of all
complex n by n matrices and inside it
there's this
small set of non-rigid matrices so we
know most
you know does like those standards
counting arguments most matrices are
rigid
most matrices require large circuits so
the set of non-rigid matrices
is small sets and it's also i i i do it
in this weird looking thing because we
really don't understand
we don't know how it looks like uh
one thing which is very natural to do i
won't have time to explain why it is
natural but you know you take my word
it's very natural
is to move from uh this like this is the
geometry world and now you move to the
algebra world
and the way you do it is you look at the
set of polynomials that are zero
on this set you this is uh we denote it
if you
it's the ideal fields is actually an
ideal uh
so this is like the there's always these
two parallel universes
there one is the geometry one is the
algebra uh
and so this is the set of a n squared
variax polynomials
the polynomial takes a matrix and some
polynomial in the inputs
in the entries of the matrix
now you can also go back from the
algebra 2 geometry
by looking at the set of zeros
of the polynomials in i of u so
just just to reiterate you start from u
then you look at all the polynomials
that are 0
u and then you look at their common
zeros so it's a set
that contains you uh obviously by
definition
but it can also contain more things
so it's called there's a little closure
of the set u it turns out that in this
case it's actually also the euclidean
closure of this that you so you
you know when you imagine the picture in
your head you can just imagine
the regular usual closure in the complex
um that you know uh
and okay this set is a is slightly
nicer in several senses uh but why
why am i telling all of this story uh
the reason is that you can think of a
nonzero polynomial in the idea of u
uh well first we call it an equation of
u and you can think of it as providing a
proof
that some matrix is is not in you it's
rigid right p of
m is non-zero means that m is rigid just
because
uh the way we pick p and if you which
means it's
zero or all non-rigid matrices
so whenever it's non-zero it means that
m
is rigid so p is for polynomial but also
for proof
it actually proves the slightest
stronger thing right it proves that m is
not in the closure of non-rigid matrices
but
we will be happy with uh with even the
weaker thing
okay but now okay so this buffet you
know they exist
somewhere uh in the world but in order
to
to to use it itself if it's simple if
it's something that we can get our hands
on and maybe
um compute or find or whatever
uh so uh well one theorem that was
proved uh
in these two papers by um kumar lokan
patankar sama and the second
is chris mundo heinstein i
and they gave some uh explicit bound on
like how how large of a degree these
equations uh can have and they so well
there's some
equation of small degree and small here
means exponential in n squared
and this is a pretty general result it
works for
any parameters for which there exists
rigid matrix says but one thing that
they conjecture is that
the parameters that are
interesting for low bound purposes so
epsilon n enter the one epsilon origin
matrix says
you can actually do much better you can
do the polynomial in n
uh and in this paper we will prove that
this thing is true
so this is the main theorem that uh
there's an equation for matrices which
are not so it's even slightly stronger
it's epsilon and
epsilon and square rigid and it has the
greatest most uh
n cubed you can even slightly improve
this not super important
epsilon here is some small constant it
doesn't have to be super small but
it is i mean so these parameters are
almost optimal they're like like a
constant factor away from optimal and
this
constant factor is actually what what
makes it makes us um
uh what helps us get the polynomial
bound
uh we can even prove a stronger thing
that uh you can just look at all
matrices that have a small circuit
uh say size of most epsilon n squared
then you can get a degree a
polynomial degree bound for an equation
for those matrices
uh yeah so i i mean the proof is not
uh complicated but i will i'm running
out of time and we
didn't plan and not say anything if you
watch the full talk you will get to see
basically the entire proof of of the
first theorem
uh and we can also prove it for for
other similar models like uh
three-dimensional tensorflow rank
uh the main downside that the open
program that i will finish with is that
the proof is
is it's non-explicit it doesn't give an
explicit
equation p explicit here could mean an
equation with a polynomial size
arithmetic circuit for example
uh there is a win-win phenomenon in the
sense that uh
if there are explicit equations of
course it's great because now maybe
we can prove these level bounds uh if
the valiant is also great because
we are sort of uh pinpointed family of
our polynomials so we
you can sort of make it into a formal
theorem
uh but the main open problem is really
uh
decide coming i mean deciding on whether
space equation exists or even coming up
with the explicit equations
uh okay i think sorry for running a
little bit out of time like
yes thank you and the
last talk of the session and the
conference is
by thomas taylor who is going to tell us
about sum of squares
bounds how they imply circuit hardness
and randomization
okay do you see my slides yes
yes okay
yes this is about the
[Music]
sum of square representation and
lower bounce rate implies circuit lower
bounds
so let's start with a sum of square
representation this
refers to polynomials there are various
settings
where sum of square representation is
considered
so we have here a weighted
sum of square representation because we
allow these
coefficients from the field uh thomas i
said can you speak a little louder
because i think
uh yeah raise the volume increase the
volume a little bit
is it better now i think so yeah yeah
okay okay
so in mathematics this would be called a
weighted
sum of square representation because we
allow these coefficients
there is a famous la crosse uh sorry uh
the hill hibbert
seventeenth problem about sum of square
representation
where this coefficient is not allowed so
ci
is one here and then it's only for
positive
and hilbert asked which polynomials can
be
represented that way also
there it was multivariate so here we
consider univariate polynomials
um as as the complexity measure we use
the sparsity of the fis
in the representation so sparsity is
simply the number of
non-zero monomials the number of
non-zero coefficients
and this we sum up and this defines
the size of f with respect to one such
representation
and then the support sum is the minimal
way you can represent
f that way
so in our case any polynomial can be
written in such a way simply by
by this formula you can easily check
that when you multiply out you get
back f and
for this complexity measure
so consider the case that f has full
sparsity
which means there are no non-zero
coefficients
that means the sparsity is degree plus
one d
plus one d is a degree and then
the support sum
is between these two bounds the upper
bound you can see from this
equation here because we have two
expressions
and each of them has a sparsity
d plus one and the lower bound you get
by a
counting argument when you take squares
you have to
have at least square root d many
monomials to end up with the monomials
so the bound is between square root d
and
a linear in the
i have two examples so that's easy
to check here so look at this polynomial
and then you can verify that you can
write it as a product in this way here
so let's call these two brackets u and v
and observe that
sparsity of each bracket is square root
d
[Music]
and when you have such a product you can
write it as a sum of squares by
by this formula here so when we now look
at the
support sum size we get
then observes that u and v both have
square root of these velocities so when
you take
u plus v or u minus v you get two square
root d
and so the
support sum is bounded by 4 square root
in this case so this is essentially at
the level bound
except for the factor 4.
if you look at this polynomial
suppose for simplicity that d is even
then you can write it that way
and that means that the support sum
[Music]
is bounded by d by 2 because you have
the sum is just one term here so that's
a trivial example um
but this bound is more at the
upper bound and actually we
think that it
the value is indeed around d
and similarly
for other polynomials we have several
candidates like this here
or this polynomial where we also think
that
the support sum should be
[Music]
around d
so why is this interesting
to consider there's a connection to
circuits and
we have just seen a
[Music]
arithmetic circuit in ben lee's talk
so vp is the class
of all polynomials that can be computed
by
polysize circuits and vnp
is the class of polynomials that can be
written as exponential sums of bp
polynomials so these are the arithmetic
analogs of
p and np and
goes back to valiant that
the permanent function can can be seen
to be complete for vnp
and the contextual is that it has super
polynomial size circuits which is
equivalent to say that
vp is different from b and b so this is
the
ultimate goal here to show
so coming back to sum of square
representation
we call a family heart
if the support sum size is a little bit
bounded away from the lower bound
so d to the uh half
plus epsilon
and actually for our purpose epsilon
must not even be a
constant it can be a function depending
on d
it just has to be larger than this
decreasing function and
the purpose is this theorem here what we
show
this is a one of our main theorems
uh we show that when one can
show existence of our heart
polynomial which means the support sum
is as of this size this already implies
vp different from enp
so observes that this is some somehow
uh surprising because here we have
a univariate polynomial whereas
this considers multivariate polynomials
and sum of square representation is
really a simple
way to express polynomials and
we just require to be a little bit away
from the lower bound
and anyway this implies vp different
from
vnp i will not go into the proof here
you can you get an overview
on the proof in the extended talk and
for the full proof you have to look in
the paper
in the stronger formulation with
constant epsilon we actually get a
exponential separation between vp and
vnp that's a
little bit different proof some
results that are somehow related
is also some of square representation
for um low bound implies
um exponential low bond for the
permanent
however this is in the non-combinative
setting here
and also the lower bound here uses a
little bit of different
complexity measures so this result you
cannot really
compare with with ours um
and there is a quarantia
who also have has a similar
looking theorem that
[Music]
is that when you have a
representation like this
and s is large that also implies vp
different from b
and p this is also univariate however
the exponent here can be larger
so we have explained two that is
quite essential
[Music]
yeah what open questions
are can we increase
decrease the hardness bound and still
get
vp different from vnp
[Music]
in the title there was also hardness to
randomness
mentioned so we know that
vp different from v and p implies that
polymer identity testing can be done in
sub-exponential time
we also consider some of cube's
representation in the paper
and there we show that
a hard polynomial would actually imply
that
polynomial identity testing is in
polynomial time it also implies vp
different from vnp
but gives a stronger denomination result
however i cheat here a little because
what i hide
in the hardness here is a bit stronger
than
the one we used for sum of square
representation
the main challenge is now to really
prove a lower bound for a sum of square
representation
that looks like is doable
hopefully thank you
oh thank you thomas uh so
uh well that was the session so let's
now move on to the
uh panel discussion and uh i have a few
questions but we can start with
questions from the audience if any of
the speakers wants to raise any
questions
oh okay i have a question from the
audience for
ben lee uh i'll just read out the
question
could you clarify p space in case of
circuit transformations
uh i'm not sure i can understand the
question so i don't know if the
uh the person who asked it wants to
ask it uh i think
they're asking about like where does the
p space come from
um okay i don't think i mentioned
space in in my talk in the paper there
is
i mean i mentioned this sort of does
like a win-win
uh uh result or i mean maybe i should
say the point is that
with the equations we find that i said
they're not explicit but there's
i mean it's just solving some some
system of linear equation and there is a
system there's a p space algorithm that
just outputs the equations like
as a list of coefficients solution to
this linear system
uh and now the point is the
that you know either this is a family of
heart polynomials and then it's great
because
we don't know how to do to find p space
family of polynomials with
super super polynomial complexity
uh but if it isn't then you can do some
other thing and get some model of a bond
uh so i actually have a question for
nathan and i'll start a bunch of
questions
uh unless somebody else wants to go
first
uh well if not let me let me actually
ask
nathan a question so
you gave a bunch of examples of
different kind of domains combinatorial
domains and how different measures of
complexity generalize or
like polynomial equivalences hold is an
example of like a theorem with relating
measures of complexity in the boolean
domain which does not seem generalizable
um let's see so
i think let's see uh
i mean maybe more generally i'm sure i'm
sure there is uh
but uh at least well maybe maybe
yeah sorry in the spirit of the in the
spirit of the conference let me make the
question very general
there's a lot of this work there's a lot
of work which is like you know this
domain like whatever we know about
boolean function analysis that carries
over to bigger domain that carries over
to
more complicated domains what seems like
a feature of the boolean domain which is
of the hypercube which is very specific
to the hypercube maybe complexity
measure
maybe some kl tfm i don't know like i'm
just saying like
something which just seems like you know
there's never going to work out in
something else
yeah that's a good question so uh
basically
anywhere where you're using like uh
where you're using nice things about the
characters of the
hypercube that does not translate to uh
these uh
non-abelian settings so there's plenty
of results in the analysis of boolean
functions they use the fact that the
characters of the hypercube form an
orthonormal basis
and then you can do you know you can
throw a lot of probability theory
to solve some of these questions that
just doesn't work uh
in these more abstract domains and then
uh and
one really i mean there's i think that
that's like the the fundamental
difference i would keep in mind between
these things
but there are things like uh like like
hyper contractivity and things like that
that
have been studied on the hypercube that
also carry over to the symmetra group so
there's some
recent result by uh phil miss uh menzer
uh kindler and uh i want to say
maybe gnome lift shits as well so
you can uh there are things that carry
over but
um i'd say it's the characters that's a
the fundamental difference between these
different domains
i can see 18 why don't you go ahead okay
yep sorry yeah i had a question for josh
um
on your last slide you have an open
problem related to algebraic proof
complexity
i was just wondering if you can make
that a bit more specific and is there
any relationship to what you
previously did about the ideal proof
system
uh yeah so i guess it's not specific to
the ideal proof system
um it's really like if i give you two
tensors
and i want to prove to you that they're
not isomorphic
you can write down a system of
polynomial equations
which is unsatisfiable if and only if
the tensors are not isomorphic so like
solutions to the polynomial equations
are change of bases that give you the
isomorphism
uh and so then you can use whatever
algebraic proof system you want to try
and prove that this system of
equations is unsatisfiable so you could
use stalinstats or pc or ips or
restricted versions of ips
whatever you want um and actually uh
in the context of graph isomorphism
there's a very nice paper by harm
dirksen where he essentially does that
for graph isomorphism with
uh polynomial calculus um
and uh yeah so there's also a question
of like can you extend
that work from graph iso to tensor iso
right yeah that sounds like a very very
natural thing to consider yeah thank you
are the other questions anyone else okay
uh actually maybe i have a i have a
question in the context of the last talk
for
thomas so um so even considering uh sum
of squares lower bounds for univariate
polynomials are they
like similar natural upper easy upper
and lower bounds for
okay maybe for multivariate polynomials
is it true that
every multivariate polynomial can be
written as a sum of squares
and are there like natural upper and
lower bounds for complexity measures and
if so what would it imply for
separation of vp and vnp
uh
actually i don't see thomas
here so
no i i don't see thomas here so
okay uh okay um
oh oh thomas okay thomas says okay okay
okay it's actually midnight it's
actually past midnight in germany okay
okay uh okay so
let me okay so after are there other
questions so we can maybe like you know
discuss another people
[Music]
all right sorry uh josh mentioned this
uh
thing about the difference between two
and three and somehow
uh is there anything we know about that
uh or anything more you can say about it
uh yeah so it's not specific to two and
three really like if you look at tensor
isomorphism over any two different
fields
uh even in the same characteristic like
f3 versus f9
uh we don't know what the situation is
um and so it's like those if you talk
about 10 stars
morphism even over different fps for
different primes p
it's like you know we kind of know what
i said you
you have the brute force algorithm
they're all in np-intersect coem
uh but but we don't know reductions
between them and they would really have
to look different than the things in our
paper
i mean the things in our paper are
really very uh
algebraic they work over whatever field
you're working over
um yeah thanks
josh you've acquired the fields of it
for your isomorphism results you require
the field to be a sufficiently large
size of something or
any field is fine well any any field is
fine
uh except for the things about
polynomials where like sometimes you
need to be able to divide
like for degree three polynomials you
need to be able to divide by six
for example to get some of these
references um
okay and actually ninja uh about your
previous question about degree four
versus degree three
i i forgot before that actually already
follows from previous work of uh agarwal
and saxena um
with one little thing that the reduction
from degree three to degree four there
was a little
a little uh complication but but the
rest of it is all in agarose xena from
15 years ago yeah
are there other questions
okay i i still have my list of questions
actually
so uh one question for
ben lee was so uh so regarding it
thinking about getting explicit
equations so
what does explicit exactly mean here
like you want to
i i'm actually not entirely sure like
some is a polynomial time like what's x
what yeah i guess i mean it could mean
what you want
basically i mean one formal notion you
can
think of is a well it's a polynomial so
explicit means
having a polynomial size arithmetic
circuit
uh okay of course it's it makes like a
non-uniform model so it's it's
kind of a weird thing where it can have
a
circuit which you wouldn't have no idea
how to find uh
so of course like the best thing would
have to be you know
explicit in the sense that you can write
it uh you know one line
in latex and compute it that would be
the best thing i don't know how
how much you should expect at this point
but
yeah you can make it uh it's the bottom
line you can make it
you can use any definition you want and
anything would be interesting
actually in the spirit of the conference
let me again ask a super open-ended
question so
we saw a lot of measures of complexity
being discussed there was a
measure of like the boolean function
analysis kind of measures of complexity
the uh all like you know things
appearing in algebraic complexity or
widgets
could there be potentially some relation
between these
that was really open-ended so i don't
have an answer but i just thought like
you know
in the spirit of the consonants let me
show it out there
i don't know i know uh eric allender who
i see is uh in the audience
uh has some some results about this
um uh let me uh uh okay maybe i can just
uh i can okay eric eric if you want to
add something i don't have
anything very uh profound to say
uh certainly there was a paper i did
with
anna gaul and and ian mertz where we
were looking
at various classes of
algebraic circuits and um
relating them very directly to certain
classes of of boolean circuits
uh peter burgesser had some results uh
quite a while ago uh relating
you know non-uniform complexity in the
boolean model to
algebraic complexity you know just
relating various open questions and
there's a
quite a few results of that form um
but i'm not sure if that was really what
you were getting at or if josh was
thinking of something different
no i think that's what i was thinking of
i don't know if it's what an india was
getting at
i i was i was not really getting at
anything in particular i was just
thinking of
just like throwing something out there
but yeah no this is this is a good
answer to my
vague questions i mean i don't know that
i've seen anything about for example
like sensitivity and that kind of thing
in the algebraic setting
yeah i mean maybe like you know i guess
related to something
uh i asked earlier then in the boolean
function
world i guess a lot of not not
complexity measures per se but things
which are like actually yeah sensitivity
is a complexity measure but
you're really thinking about like
isoparametry right like you know how
much surface area is there
and it's not clear like you know those
kind of notions necessarily
always generalize to other domains
and maybe that those kind of things can
also be
hard to talk i guess yeah like you know
without an
underlying metric i find it very hard to
think about
things like surface area what would it
mean if you put up the function a little
bit
and now if you think about finite fields
or where most of algebraic complexity is
done
is there a notion of metric is there is
this a metric you can endow
the domain with sure
so for there are natural notions of uh
of the of a metric space for uh
permutations
uh perfect matchings uh subsets and
things like that
and uh in our in our you know i didn't
have time to
to discuss it but uh i think we give a
satisfactory definition of uh
sensitivity
in uh the domains of uh the symmetric
group
and perfect matchings uh but as one of
my open questions states
that we weren't able to extend this to
like say hypergraphic
or hyper graph matchings or things like
that so uh
so yeah i i think they're well defined
and in fact like noise sensitivity was
even
studied before our work which is
slightly different
than the definition that we give in our
paper uh so check out works by carl
wimmer and uh o'donnell
uh from like uh like 10 years ago
like uh yeah you might find that
interesting yeah i mean
somehow like you know i i guess like
those works are like there was a graph
and so there was naturally some sort of
a metric defined because there's an edge
so you know what is moving by one means
just wondering like i guess in the
finite field or something
it's not like three comes after two and
before four like
that that notion might not be there so
finite feels it might be a little harder
to define metric but again like you know
i
mean i didn't have anything particular
i think you're touching upon some of the
difficulties that even we encountered
when trying to wrestle with some of
these q analogs so like uh you know
like grasping graphs and things like
that i mean it's uh
yeah it's uh it's difficult to capture
them in our framework so
yeah let's yeah that's one of our open
questions so uh
[Music]
are there any other questions we can
keep the discussion going this was
this is the last session of the
conference
okay some ovi has a question but he's
typing the question so
we'll wait
in the meantime if somebody else has
another question
okay there is a connection between in
okay if uv
is uh
uh sorry over you can also unmute and
ask like you can just you don't have to
type the question
okay i'm i'm reading out of these
questions sorry
okay i'm reading out yuvi's question uh
oh his mic is jammed he says
there's a connection between influence
and the probability of probing
in a decision tree algorithm might that
extend to more than just a boolean
setting
i guess there's there are decision tree
i'll write decision tree construction
algorithms where you look at the
influence of the variables
i think the result is bkkl okay yeah the
b triple k
l so uh might
that extend to more than just a boolean
setting
it's uh yeah
i'd have to take a look at that result
to
to stay one way or the other uh um i i'm
not familiar with it but
uh let's see
so yeah i mean i guess this is another
open question that i didn't state uh i
mean
we only had uh i mean our paper was
already 60 pages with just the
complexity messages
that we mentioned in that paper so you
have to draw the line somewhere and so
uh i would be interested in seeing uh if
other
if other nice results in the analysis of
boolean functions if you can find
analogs for
these other more you know complicated
domains and
if the ingredients are just decision
trees and
a notion of influence which uh you get
uh from definitions of sensitivity
then uh it seems quite possible but i
don't want to say
for sure one way or the other
josh actually had a question for you it
was clarifying question really
so you said something concerning that uh
something about tensors the notion of
tensors and machine learning and how
like you know something is a genuine
tensor what's the
i do not know how tensors differ from an
array of numbers so
uh yeah so what's what's the what's the
notion of a tensor
tensors like for an array of number to
be tensors it should
really be like you should have a notion
either of like a way of contracting it
with another tensor like you know
multiplying a matrix by a vector
or like change of basis where you know
there's some vector space floating
around and if you change basis in the
vector space it changes basis linearly
or multi-linearly in the tensor and so
there are lots of you know like
tensorflow is most
not actually about tensors it's just
about high-dimensional arrays
but but my point was there are actually
some sort of genuine tensors that are
like multi-linear algebra
that that show up in yeah okay so you
think they can
start like sorry god sorry well no no
yeah
i was just going to say that you know so
you do not you're saying
an array of numbers can be a tensor but
you have to end up with some other
operations like if they define a notion
of contraction
and transformation something else like
it cannot just be an array of numbers in
itself
makes any right right same vector or
matrix like yeah i could call any array
of numbers a vector but i only do that
if i'm going to
treat it as a vector in a vector space
right like yes
are there any other questions anybody
else wants to
[Music]
pose a question uh well i i had a
question from
actually uh though you mentioned in this
like abstract simplicial complex
framework
you sort of always have some action of
sn floating around
and like it's the representation theory
of that that somehow gets things
started uh do you have things for
if you have an action of some other
group on on your
universe yeah so
uh this gets back to the question of q
analog so we tried doing something with
like say gl and q acting
and um it just uh
just um i mean
it's we we just couldn't like i guess
the best way of saying this is that like
there is no like natural uh
way of talking about say like k element
subspaces and like some uh
or sorry k dimensional subspaces as
being like some sort of
uh simplicial complex and it's uh
at least i'm not aware of it um and and
that's sort of i think at the heart of
like
why uh other actions like say like
gl and q uh they don't like fit into our
framework
um yeah that's a good question though i
mean it's uh like
for combinatorics we chose sn because
that's uh
there's even that quote right like uh
you know
maybe it's uh yeah i forget who said it
but like
all of combinatorics can be encoded as
like representation theory
of the symmetric group it seems a bit
bold but i think somebody said it before
so uh
so yeah that's why we chose that's why
we chose sn so uh
but yeah are there other groups i don't
know that's a good question
are there any other questions anybody
else has any remark
well if not then actually let's thank
all the speakers in this session
and we can then end the
panel now
thank you